Mike sir penis for now yep that's not
touching me by the way it just looks
like it is hello reject nation I'm Greg
Alva and I'm John Humphrey this is Julie
Julie Zahn is returning to the channel
she's back we're here today we're gonna
check out Netflix's original content
the Magic School Bus rides again we were
all talking beforehand we we all watch
the magic school it's true young I don't
remember jack about the matter I
remember one episode they like went into
someone's intestines now I think I
remember that was a memorable ass
episode this is no redhead lady who's
this that's the mrs. I don't know her
name yeah Wow the wacky redheaded lady
who like drives the bus and like learns
kids about stuff clearly i watch this
show and all the kids were diapers they
remember correctly they use this as like
a teaching aid like half the time in
school and today's patron of the day
shoutout gonna go out to Diego shy Dez
keep a lookout Diego gonna give you a
shout-out hey man it's all a nostalgia
nostalgia now what's down this sells 90s
dude she is hot it's missing
whoa thanks sis come along everyone okay
okay my big sister always there yeah
[Music]
Oh their parents know they do this
though no no permission
[Music]
okay Kenan I'm into this this might not
be the first thing I gravitate towards
when I add this to my list on Netflix
when it comes out but I kind of want to
check it out for like nostalgia purposes
actually yeah you know on a Saturday
morning yeah ever some cereal as I did
grow up watching this show before we
would go to school and then I would be
playing my ate cereal miss Frizzle looks
hot she looks friggin hot wait yeah what
changed about her sister oh gee miss
when I've stated her style yeah why
she's aged a [ __ ] she's a grown woman
all right she can do what she wants she
can adapt a new hairdo
whatever she looks exactly the same and
even younger she looks younger that's
what the students look older
well maybe here's that maybe this is
just years before I mean clearly space
and time don't matter that much care
about grounded realism when it comes to
the Magic School Bus we're on the
timeline this is or which this is a new
universe okay this is the Rick and Morty
of children's TV now I don't know if
that's a good descriptor for this but
while I was watching this little ad I
was like I feel like this is like a cute
version of Rick and more there's gonna
go on adventures learn some science
maybe mess up space-time and come back I
wonder who this is being made for I'm
sure that's gonna ask that what's your
demographic like can what dholtze watch
it I mean yeah because I'm like one of
the people who like we're grown up now
it's not something I would normally put
on but I might watch it for a nostalgia
purposes the same because they're
putting like Kate McKinnon I'm like what
kid knows who Kate McKinnon is that's a
that's a drop for adults right yeah
nostalgia is enormous yeah you know that
people our age especially will tune in
to check because the other thing about
the show as I recall it anyway was they
did bother to try and teach you a little
bit
so you know I can imagine a lot of
Millennials being like I'm gonna learn
basic science and every visit this show
I used to look you know what it is we're
supposed to have had kids by now so it's
the nostalgia of yeah yeah we're
watching this that are gonna force their
now children to watch it exactly it's
like hey adults here's Kate McKinnon for
you guys yeah kids here's the rest of
you I don't see Mike and Lily Tomlin
my children are we're in a custody
battle right now right my ex wants me to
see them I kind of don't I mean do what
you want I'm busy I don't have time to
raise a kid maybe this would be good for
him or her
I forget what gender my child once in a
while or they I think they were twins I
definitely wasn't there for the first
one being born you know what we don't
need to talk about this is all personal
and I say too much I can make the
lawsuit even worse miss Frizzle is back
and miss Frizzle is she's a hot her
younger sister is even hotter her before
I watch like an episode I'm so excited
forget stranger things the season two
this is what I'm tuning in this is the
upside-down
iemon yeah I'm a 90s boy oh yeah and
shadow today Diego shy Dez Diego we made
sure to cool me it is a cool name and
he's a handsome guy but he's only 17
years old so watching in every bro call
it hot yet we can't come we can we go
about his he will be good-looking in the
future yeah I'm telling you like right
now oh man oh man I cannot wait to tell
you when he's 18 how hot he is oh boy is
he is so oh man he is so potentially
hostile potentially hot until I'm
legally allowed to say how might this
guy is I figured Diego you're still in
high school so you probably still ride
the school bus you should watch that you
should watch that
you know you should pull up this video
on the school bus on your way to school
and show somebody that you're super
awesome public YouTube shout-out I'm not
gonna give too much information here he
did tell us he has a crush on someone
[Applause]
can I say her name I remember the name
I'm not gonna give any facts so she
doesn't know in case she happens to
stumble across this video oh actually
that's what I was trying to get him to
do I'm trying to give give advice tips
be a nice guy uh no it was work it
totally were have you ever dated a nice
guy oh my god
all the time listen how's that pattern
genuinely get to know her as a person
oh my god jeez we'll just ask for you
yeah we'll show up yeah we'll come to
your high school show up there and one
I'm like two men with facial hair
showing up at a high school yeah and
we'll go directly to the girl
it'll be very comfortable listen Diego
he's beautiful but we can't say that yet
go to prom yeah you can subscribe to the
real rejects if you want to click that
notification bell do it it might do
something good for your life dad John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram become
a patron Oh jack today do it but ignore
all that if you can and go to YouTube
shut up and dance all one word
Julie's aunts channel wide variety on
there she has these two action films
have been up in the last couple months
that are fantastic come on cactus that
was amazing it's her versing a cactus
tough competitor not much mobility this
bikes hurts though oh so she is dance
juju dance on Instagram and Twitter
constantly half-naked on all her posts
that's what she does best and that's why
her instagrams blowing up
yeah that's me just tons of cleavage and
paragraphs upon paragraphs of
inspirational ponderings while showing
off her ass yeah and the Magic School
Bus rides again people take care